So this is a demonstration of a lexical analyzer.
And what I'm going to show you is
how to test things out or change things around.
For example, let's go up here and turn "This" into a quoted string.
So previously, our first token was the WORD, ' This ',
but when I rerun it, I'm really expecting to see the STRING, "This"--
because I've put This in quotes.
And now it is the STRING, ' This '.
These other numbers,
after lexical analyzer token STRING, with token value, ' This '
are the line and character number information.
The token corresponding to ' This ' starts on line 1, at character zero.
The token corresponding to ' is ' starts on line 1, character 7--
zero, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7--yep, that's where the "i" starts.
So let's say we made a mistake,
we got one of our regular expressions wrong.
Let's say that I mistakenly put in a Greater Than sign here,
for LANGLESLASH.
Well, then right after "my", I would expect to see the output change.
I'm going to expect to see us get the wrong answer.
Currently, right after ' my ', we see LANGLESLASH.
Let's rerun it.
Oh! Now we don't see quite the right thing at all.
Right after the ' b ', we see an LANGLESLASH,
but it's associated with the wrong text.
After ' my ', we just see an LANGLE.
The slash is made its way into this WORD, ' /b '.
By looking at this output,
we can notice mistakes in our lexical analyzer and help fix them.
I repair the problem,
rerun, and the world looks like a bit better.
Here, I've used Python's triple quoting approach.
We have the word Tricky; the quoted STRING, "string";
LANGLE, word, RANGLE, output, LANGLE, slash, i, RANGLE, word--
and then we're done.
Let's go see how this comes out.
We've got the word Tricky; the STRING, "string"--
and if you've noticed, we've shaved off the 2 double quotes,
which is just what we wanted,
an LANGLE, the i, the RANGLE, the word ' output ', LANGLESLASH,
Bang at the end.